as you know as an entrepreneur the every
day is a challenge right there you have
new problems to solve every day and so
what works today is likely not going to
work in 6 to 12 months from now and so I
think the mind having a mindset where
you are ready to adapt and change is
really critical to being successful um
you can't ever get too complacent and
think that just because this worked for
me last season it's going to work for me
again and so if you go into it
open-minded and you know that you have
to kind of pivot and change and shift
strategies throughout I think you're
more prepared to question why is
something working and will it continue
to
[Music]
work Carrie Michaels welcome to
20-minute leaders thank you so much for
joining me today how are you Michael
thank Michael thank you so much for
having me this is a pleasure
I really appreciate you joining me from
Austin and you're the co-founder and CEO
of William marolf and uh I have a
feeling that we're going to be ex you
know we're in for quite a treat of an
entrepreneurial story I can already I
something about the something about the
energy already tells me this and so
without further Ado I'd love to to get
started right over there takeing me to
the first of all a little bit about
yourself you know what your connection
to golf is how did you even enter this
whole space and then I want to to hear
about the founding of the company yeah
absolutely um so to really start you
know I grew up always wanting to be an
entrepreneur uh my dad's an entrepreneur
so I always very much looked up to him
um so I always felt like it was kind of
in my blood but you know after college I
didn't know what I wanted to do or what
what that idea was yet so um my first
job out of school was in marketing
research
Consulting um and then from there you
know quick overview I went back to
business school and I was like you know
I really want a broader background in
business you know across a lot of
different areas um and so I went back
and I kind of studied a lot of different
things I didn't have a specific Focus um
and after grad school again I kind of
jumped around and I know I remember at
one point being like Oh my resume looks
like you know I'm all over the place
I've been in marketing and finance
strategy operations um I really just
love I love business and so I always
wanted to kind of get my hands in
different parts of it um and I think
that's really what helped prepare me and
to feel confident going into this
startup Journey um was having that broad
base and that broad background where I
had touched so many different things
throughout my career career so that was
kind of the the start of it but I I
always have thought like an entrepreneur
and so I was working here in Austin
Texas for another company called The
Chive uh have you heard of it I've heard
of the name yeah yeah so um it was a
humor Media Company um but they also had
an
e-commerce uh Division and they were
selling funny t-shirts and it was a very
very um big business and they had a huge
following and some of the t-shirts they
were doing actually had Bill's face on
the front of them um and that was a huge
business for them so when I came in as
head of
operations uh I was just blown away by
this community of people um and I had
come from Oakley I loved that sport
performance World um I did I did really
enjoy golf um and so I had seen one of
the t-shirts they sold at the Chive has
our now William golf logo on it um and
it's a picture of Bill tossing his golf
club and they did this t-shirt for
charity uh I think they sold I don't
know 2,000 units in 24 hours or
something crazy um and I was like wow
that's that's pretty cool that's a great
shirt um but it seems like it could be
something bigger you know it seems like
you know with that kind of logo and um
people really ate it up uh I felt like
there was a brand there so you know in
chatting with the founders at the Chive
you know I said gosh wouldn't this be
fun you know to start a brand to start a
golf apparel line with
Bill and you know had mixed reviews
internally you know they were like yeah
it would be really cool but everyone
says Bill's never going to say yes to an
IDE like this again you know we have his
license on t-shirts we should just be
okay with that and move on uh so you
know the entrepreneurial side of me was
like okay that's fine but do you mind if
I still work on the business idea and
the concept because I think there's a
huge opportunity and I just want to
explore it a little further so they said
yeah go for it um and really the white
space that I saw was that nobody in golf
was doing anything fun I mean there was
nothing disruptive about it you know you
kind of squinted your eyes and all the
big players looked exactly the same you
know you couldn't differentiate one from
the other um and you know I called it
the sea blue strip polos everyone
everyone was the same so I was like well
why why does it have to be like that why
do guys have to wear a uniform on the
course that doesn't seem fun by the way
why how did we get to this point you
know why why is is this sort of the
tradition just something very old old
school tradition right exactly why so
that was where it stemmed from and then
I was like well you know the Chive has
this you know great community of people
that love Bill Murray um so he clearly
has a ton of personality and people love
his movies you know what if he was the
face of this movement in Gulf um where
it was to break away from the norm and
to do something a little different so
that was the original idea you know I'll
say it took us um I I incubated this
company under the Chive with my
co-founder Brandon Barrett who was also
at the chive and very involved in golf
um and so he and I incubated it there
for a few months and then we split off
and became our own company in
2017 wow okay so you you came your own
company in
2017 take me to that to the sort of that
moment where you're sort of sitting
there with you know with your co-founder
and you're thinking about you know how
the how how this is going to unfold what
is the strategy that you have in terms
of creating you know a brand for this
you're going to break some some Trends
and you're going to create some new
trends of your own what what is the
thing what is the vision that you're
setting out in the strategy that you're
laying out for this so there were a
couple things you know I think the first
thing was that you know we didn't want
to create this loud golf brand with
crazy prints um just because right we I
wanted everything that we did to be
rooted in something that was meaningful
and had purpose and told a story you
know I think people really connect to
brands that do a great job at telling
stories so that was a key first part of
it for me and so every design to this
day that we do um tells a story about
either bill and his family's love for
golf um some of their stories from
growing up um and then also you know
stories about you know Bill's movies and
so every print there's something you
know meaningful there I think the second
part of our strategy really was how we
went to Market uh I had a background in
um Ecom and direct to Consumer and when
I was at Oakley actually I kind of saw
the flip side you know I saw what the
wholesale model looked like and I worked
with reps around the world very closely
and I saw how difficult that process was
and so when we started William Murray
Golf we said listen let's be primarily
focused on direct to Consumer because we
have an icon and a brand you know with
Bill Murray as a face of this we can get
a lot of brand awareness but let's let's
go direct to the consumer on this and
streamline the business because when you
have to start start hiring reps and
going into green grass retail and trying
to scale that way that is how 99% of the
golf Brands out there have built their
brands um but it's a difficult path and
it it can take a long time to grow and
so we wanted to grow just a little bit
faster um and direct to
Consumer uh really we felt was the
answer wow okay and how and how how did
that work you so you're going direct to
Consumer obviously this is a is it is it
a competitive market is it a Satur I
mean how do you even do direct a
consumer for golf apparel I mean what
what did you learn or sort of what were
the assumptions behind the golf audience
that they are you know how do you even
get them yeah so you know I mean golf is
one of the most popular sports in the
world I mean you know there it is a a
huge Market when you look at the
opportunity um and so for us it's worked
really well you know I think having
again having bill as the face has
allowed us to get a lot of press and so
from the get-go we were getting a lot of
pressed and stories about us so we we
sold out of our first collection in the
spring of 2016 was gone within that
first week so we actually I remember was
that fall by the time we got to the
holidays we had nothing to sell um we
didn't even I think in 2016 we sent out
one email and that was the launch email
and I think that was
it so um you know it was that was an
interesting way to start the company I
think since then you know we are we
operate much more like a typical Ecom
business and our marketing strategies
and acquiring new customers and whatnot
but we definitely had a nice Head Start
so with with the bill and I can only
imagine the fun it is to have his to
have his own personality be be a part of
this I'm just looking here on you know
I'm looking at his smiley face with a
with a pink and blue you know flower
shirt and immediately
thinking Groundhog Day and uh you know
when H how sustain how how does that
sustain or I'll ask in different way how
do you as an entrepreneur realize sort
of when it's time to grow and when you
sort of when you outgrow certain
processes you mentioned that this may be
a good head start for for a
company but then you mentioned that you
may that that today you're operating
much more as a traditional U you know
e-commerce business so how do you know
you know as an entrepreneur to make that
to make that leap yeah you know as you
know as an entrepreneur the every day is
a challenge right there you have new
problems to solve every day and so what
works today
is likely not going to work in 6 to 12
months from now and so I think the mind
having a mindset where you are ready to
adapt and change is really critical to
being successful um you can't ever get
too complacent and think that just
because this worked for me last season
it's going to work for me again and so
if you go into it open-minded and you
know that you have to kind of pivot and
change and shift strategies throughout I
think you're more prepared to question
why is something working and will it
continue to work um you know I think
having key metrics in things benchmarks
to kind of show was this a successful
campaign well I don't know what were we
trying to accomplish with it what did we
think it was going to do and so making
sure that you're challenging yourself
and challenging those assumptions is
really important along the way yeah tell
me a little bit about you know the
fundraising for this you you did raise
you know money for this and what what
what is so the you know the thoughts
behind that and this is sort of you know
Bridging the Gap between sort of my own
experience from VC backed companies to
more you know businesses or more
traditional businesses so I'm curious to
hear about the strategy with funding
here yeah so um when my co-founder
Brandon and I split off from the Chive
in early
2017 we had to kind of hit the ground
running and start raising our own
Capital uh when you're in the apparel
business it is very Capital intensive to
buy that inventory and when we were
growing fast we wanted to buy you know
more and more inventory you know 9
months in advance of it coming and so it
was an expensive it's an expensive
business um we were very fortunate
because um the founder of the Chive John
resig also had a podcast at the time
when we started this and so he had a
great network of people that he was able
to introduce us to when we started
fundraising and so from there you know I
kind of call it it's like a network
effect it's like a spiderweb um one
person leads you to another leads you to
another and you know I think the advice
I always give people is never be afraid
even if it is a no if someone's telling
you no sorry this isn't the right
investment never be afraid to ask them
if there's anyone in their Network they
might know that could be a good fit for
what you're doing and might be
interested because what I have found is
that about nine times out of 10 somebody
will say you know what yeah actually you
know I have a good friend who loves Golf
and this person might be a good fit um
so we did attempt to go down the VC
route early on and I think fortunately
for us it didn't work out I know we you
know we weren't the right type of
business for what they were looking for
um and in retrospect I get that now um
VC is not for everybody nor and and it
shouldn't be and so we have about 70
investors um all Angel all Angel
Investors um and that's also you know
has its own challenges uh but you know
every it seems like every year we've
kind of raised little bits and pieces
along the way that's that's really
really cool tell me a little bit about
your own experience you've you've given
you've given me bits and bites
throughout this the last 15 minutes but
what is what is this been like for you
as the entrepreneur you said something
before about the the daily challenges
and the daily struggle but you said it
in in a way that it seemed like you you
really enjoy it I I love being an
entrepreneur I think um there's there's
so many things about this journey that
are exciting you know it is not for the
faint of heart right every day
is has its own challenges and I'm
learning stuff about myself all along
the way but to be able
to create a vision from scratch and to
figure out you know all the things that
go into it and to to shape it and mold
it every day I mean that is cool um and
I get so excited when I see someone
wearing William Murray Golf in the wild
is what I call it like you know I just I
I don't know what it is I just get so
excited I'm like oh my gosh there's a
customer I see them and you know I love
going up to them and just saying hey I
love your shirt and they have no idea
who I am um and their faces always light
up and they get really excited and so
for me um that you know produces so much
I'm so proud and so excited for for the
brand and for the team um so there's
there's a lot of things I love about you
know being an entrepreneur uh but you
you know we're learning and growing
every day if you had to you know if I'm
looking at this journey that you're on
and and then you had to sort of do some
reflection on what was most successful
for you um in you know dealing with the
challenges and dealing with a daily
struggle while being so activated and
being so on it when you
are obviously raising from 70 Angels
what what what what what advice do you
have sort of for yourself or some as
some sort of reflection raising from 70
Angels requires quite a bit of
commitment it's it's a it's not a it's
not easier than raising from a from a
top tier VC fund requires a lot of trust
a lot of trust building and a lot of
community yeah you know it really does I
I do feel grateful because I think we
have an amazing group of um of investors
you know it's really important I tell
people this all the time it's so
important to keep your investors up to
dat on not just the good but the Bad and
the Ugly too because that's the that's
the reality of running a business is not
it's not all easy and so I think
building that trust with investors where
they know that when I tell them we're
going through a tough time that it
really must be a tough time um and they
listen and they pay attention um and so
I think that's part of building that
community is building the trust that
they can rely on the information um that
you're sharing with
them and um and you know I think that's
that's key to being successful in the
future too yeah and so you know a few
words on building trust with your
customers as they approach your brand
beyond the very friendly face how what
what did you learn about being
successful there well what's fascinating
is that when customers reach out to us
they think Bill Murray is on the other
side you know they expect and think that
Bill's going to be answering their
emails and so I remember figuring this
out just a couple weeks into selling um
and my founder Brandon and I we were
like gosh you know the customer has
always got to be at the center of what
we do and I want to talk to them all I
want to answer every email as fast as
possible I mean Brandon and I were
customer service for the first few years
um um and so I think that was that's
really important and honestly I still
talk to customers I still want to hear
what they have to say um and that is
something that is never lost on me um
our team does a really great job of
making sure that you know our our think
our average response time with customers
is like you know 10 to 12 hours and so
you know you're going to hear from us
and you're going to hear from a real
person and I think people appreciate
that and you know there are going to be
challenges and there are things you know
a package is late or you shi the wrong
you know item or whatnot in my mind
those are opportunities to build a
relationship with that customer and
acknowledge you know that there was a
problem and you say yeah gosh sorry that
sucks um what can we do to make this
right and I think so often people are
scared to say that they messed up and to
build the relationship and trust with
your consumer you have to acknowledge
when and where you went wrong wow I love
that Kelly thank you so much Carrie
Kelly Carrie Carrie thank you it happens
all the time thank you I'm sure I'm sure
that it does by the way it's h but both
of them are beautiful names but uh
Carrie I really appreciate your time and
and I just love the I love the energy
that I and I mentioned this at the
beginning of the conversation the energy
that you brought
to to the conversation and and you know
from from the founding story as well
starting with entrepreneurship
transitioning to entrepreneurship
building this trust with the community
around you which is not trivial at all
um and and following up with customer
Obsession and creating really meaningful
trust in in what you're building I think
that's just really awesome so thank you
very much for for you know bringing me
into this journey over these 20 short
but very insightful minutes I really
appreciate it and H I wish you best of
luck with with everything that you're
doing and with everything that you'll
continue doing and I look forward to
being cheering from the side thank you
thank you so much Michael it's been a
pleasure chatting with you and and best
of luck to you as well I appreciate that
thank you
[Music]